[Musik]
mit marina die us serie sons kielerin
und bloggerinnen und ich bin im 2008 ein
guter freund vergewaltigt hatte mein
name ist luisa ich bin 21 jahre alt
schauspielschülerin und habe sexuelle
gewalt erlebt
ich bin nur in der wiese ich bin 25
jahre alt studentin aktivisten
blockerinnen und ich habe mit 19 jahren
sexualisierte gewalt erlebt und wurde
oral vergewaltigt mein name ist modell
ich befehle 20 42 nicht hin und
bloggerin und als dritter jährige
wirklich vergewaltigt wurde
[Musik]
zwei mal fliegt mir letztens tore
gemacht kam zum thema sexuelle gewalt
und re und imf erzählt dass ich das auto
mit liza li und ich bin so überwältigt
sie fordere kündige ich habe mich letzte
offerte entschieden meine geschichte auf
instagram steilen öffentlicher für jede
will ich in der letzten jahre immer
wieder mit dem thema konfrontiert wurde
bin und ich immer wieder zu spüren
bekommen dass frauen so sachen erlebt
und ermutigt andere beträge vergewaltigt
das kann jetzt sagen kann ich es ganz
klar aussprechen vergewaltigung ein
thema welches auf instagram nichts
verloren hat
etwa so viel wie opfer von sexuellem
missbrauch uns schämen müssten
es geht doch niemanden etwas an dass du
und andere vergewaltigt worden wie mir
ist das so sieht das mit schulkollegen
halt verfolgt hat also vorherrsche
sowohl sie hat ein paar stunden später
habe ich den extra dafür entsteht ein
anderes niveau nicht so hatte und
natürlich dem gleich gefolgt mit dem
capped mit byd machen ich habe ich
probiert es wieder ich habe auch ruhe
und dann hört doch auf den ist schneller
und noch damit mich zu verstehen und
mich auch verletzt haben wo am boden und
lager sind habe ich für mich einfach
endlos über michel hat man logo und eine
technologie und damit mit sicherheit zum
ihre mutter genau zum in der familie
[Musik]
bei dem blogbeitrag habe ich meine
geschichte geteilt zum ersten mal und
geschrieben warum wir endlich reden
müssen über sexualisierte gewalt und mit
einem brief an mich selbst angefangen
liebe juni du bist 19 jahre alt und
wirst in fünf jahren über deine
erlebnisse mit sexualisierter gewalt
schreiben öffentlich es wird dir egal
sein was die leute denken weil du weißt
dass du nicht alleine damit wirst
sexistischer kag chance hast bis dahin
ein für alle mal den kampf angesagt
ich war damals 19 jahre alt und mein
jura camp in dänemark und der täter war
im endeffekt einer aus der gruppe mit
dem ich mich sehr gut verstanden habe
und zu dem ich auch vertrauen hatte er
hat irgendwann die idee kommen wir gehen
mal im wald spazieren und fand das cool
von der gruppe mal weg zu gehen und habe
mir ehrlich nichts dabei gedacht du hast
einen kanten kopf ich schaue mich um und
sehe blätterwald
ich laufe locker denke bei bald küsste
mich leicht kreis oder laufen nur im
wald im kreis und ganz stehen blieben
und hat mich angeschaut und mich auf
französisch gefragt ob ich ihm einen
blasen will und ich war total befreit
mit der frage weil ich die nicht
abkommen sehen und hat dann auch
ziemlich in meinen kopf genommen
und mich festgehalten während er mit
penetriert hat und auf bin ich rein und
ich schaue dir zu wie du von oben stehen
mich penetriert wie du mehr und mehr die
kontrolle verliert seine hände sind fest
um meinen kopf meine lippen um deinen es
war einfach für mich als sie das erlebt
hat sei widerlich weil ich in würgereiz
hatte und ich habe kaum luft bekommen
und habe mich dann irgendwie irgendwann
von ihm weg gezogen als er gekommen ist
weil ich dass sie täglich fand und war
danach irgendwie total überfordert mit
der situation
[Musik]
ich habe es versucht mit mir selbst
auszumachen ich habe nie versucht weg zu
waschen unter der dusche glaubt es geht
auch einigen opfern so was natürlich
nicht viel bringt ja und bin halt
einfach damit er alleine geblieben
also nachdem das passiert ich bin ich
heimisch denn schon vor der tür
gestanden wird probiert aus liegt aber
ich habe mein handy nico und da man so
nicht die hupen hat sie eine stelle zu
suchen und heimlich darauf was ich unter
schock gestanden ich bin blutverschmiert
sie habe das wohl diese praktika nur
kühle und der haben sie hätten gerade
reagiert und ich habe ich gehört zu der
polizei unmittelbar nach der ganzes auch
hatte ich das einfach versucht spiele
ich habe funktioniert ich habe in der
schule einfach so wichtig ist auch dass
sich mehr mediziner haben zum das
verarbeiten und mit extrem wichtig sie
dass ich weitermachen haben dass ich
meine lehre machen kann weil ich meine
ich für zukunft wichtig und das ist ein
aktuell sie und ich habe mich so fest
dass eine stiege zu zeigen dass ich das
einfach komplett ausblendet haben
vielleicht hat er sei bewusst sachlich
gemacht um das erbe und mit ihm über den
kopf ziehen
die angst vor foto sich vor dem
seelischen schwarz kam und also bewusst
einfach dann ganz okay der inneren sind
jeden tag aufgehoben menschlich sehr gut
conow city andere mal weniger gut und
und eine schmerzliche mit ochsen oder
und ich glaube da wird noch lang da sie
drei tage vor heiligabend wurde ich
vergewaltigt nicht von einem fremden
nicht auf dem heimweg nicht in einer
dunklen gasse sondern ihnen vier wänden
eines feindes der hand aber film läuft
wie in der heimischen absolutes problems
sie und haben dafür und und mit meiner
alten abstand ganz links und rechts und
immer wieder fragt ob eine kleine gut
mit dem abstand und danach ein jahr nach
dem 5 1 für mich selber michael so
plötzlich einfach vor mit kaufen
dennis losgar bce-chef sie auch nicht
erwartet kann gerne probiert wachse
schon am anfang
hopfen ist probiert also im hof aktie
schloss an der schulter aber er hat
ziemlich schnell gemerkt dass ich ihn
komplett unterlagen und nicht nur das
mit kabarett plötzlich selber resigniert
die haben wir gut gespielt er hat am
liebsten aber die hab ich spüre dass er
sie nie machen bewege dieses für also
ich hatte wirklich bis an das gefühl
dass ich neben mehr stehen ich habe
schon mitgekriegt alles sehr direkt aber
ich habe mich sehr machtlos gefühlt gut
da waren zum einen die die hände um
meinen kopf aber mein körper hat
irgendwie einfach mitgemacht und
funktioniert der handlungsspielraum
wattens auch eines der dinge die mich
eigentlich fertig macht weil es hätte so
viel anders laufen können es ist aber
nicht und ich glaube das sehen viele
menschen sehr falsch dass sie denken
hier erhältst du dich gewährt und so es
ist sehr einfach das zu sagen wenn man
es nicht erlebt hat
wie stark muss sich der 34 jährige mit 6
gang ihre wähler strafbar ist sehr aktiv
sie muss früh pfiffe gegen wir
körperliche gegenwehr leisten wirklich
das ganze blut kultur dass sie das nicht
will oder flüchten also das muss mir
bewiesen dass sie das gemacht
sie muss das einfach mindestens glaube
auftritte darlegte dass sie das gemacht
und sie muss dazu sagen also nicht darum
sagen selber schuld also das würde ich
ständig jetzt jeden tag muss ich unter
glas ist nicht nur heute sind machen
ganz klar christian von weiterhin eine
mitschuld tragen und ich weigere mich zu
akzeptieren
ich sage mal auf instagram alles
mögliche aktivistische und auch zum
thema vergewaltigung und sexualisierte
gewalt und dieses bild habe ich gemacht
als ich gemerkt habe es gibt keinen weg
zurück und die flashbacks er präsent
waren
und dann habe ich mich auf die suche
gemacht und mehr geblockt und gepostet
nur wenn wir reden können wir uns sehen
und verbinden und uns gegenwärtig
stärken gerade im moment passiert so
viel es gibt extrem viele menschen die
anfangen zu sprechen viele mutige frauen
und ich glaube die veränderung ist und
im vollen gange das gefühl wenn ich
meine eigene geschichte erzählen die
youtuber zu lassen
wenn ich einfach solche sätze was ihr
probiert hat jahrelang ohne zeit
das arbeiten von petra wozny täglicher
war ja nicht gleich viel aufmerksamkeit
für das thema also bewirkt mit dem ziel
dass es thematisiert betet dann gab es
ein poetry slam
das ging um für ministers und ja ein
paar dinge und ich dachte so das ist
genau die plattformen wo du deine
geschichte eigentlich mal laut sagen
könntest
und da war extrem viel angst in mir und
richtig panik und ich habe also meine
geschichte zum ersten mal laut gesagt
vor menschen auf einer bühne
ich frage mich gerade wie das geschehen
kann ich mir das nicht wollen
dabei nicht kapiert ähnlich ist das team
in den hals zu schenken dass das nicht
zeigen und ich war danach einfach
erleichtert dass es draußen war und als
eine der ersten reaktionen kamen an dem
abend an die junge frau zu mir die nur
mit mir sprechen wollte mich anschaute
und zu meinte danke das war meine
geschichte und dann hat sie geweint und
ich darf in hose christen wie viele sind
hier die die diese oder eine ähnliche
geschichte hat haben
ich war 15 jahre alt und ich habe
jemanden kennengelernt gehabt den ich
auch total toll fand und wir waren also
wir waren wirklich so wir haben uns
irgendwie haben uns irgendwie alles
erzählt und es war richtig schön ich
habe der person auch vertraut aber ich
hatte so ein also der bei der wahl
gleich alt wie ich also es war so ich
habe zu ihm gesagt dass ich ihnen nicht
küssen will als er es versucht hat dann
hat er zuerst es gelassen und wieder
probiert und wieder probiert und
irgendwann hat sich quasi gereicht er
wollte sich von mir nicht so
zurückweisen lassen und hat eben meinen
nein dann auch übergangen und hat mich
einfach an gefasst obwohl ich nicht
wollte und irgendwann lag ich dann so da
die hände rechts und links vom kopf die
er festgehalten hat und er lag eben auf
mir drauf hat versucht mich zu küssen
hat mir die klamotten ausgezogen hat mir
gesagt was ich machen muss was alles
meine schuld ist und hat mich auch
geschlagen
ich habe früher ungefähr zwei bis drei
oder öfter panikattacken in der woche
gehabt und mittlerweile geht es mir
eigentlich sehr gut mit dem thema also
ich kann auch wieder körperliche nähe
haben ohne dass ich panik bekommen und
ich weiß mittlerweile einfach die schuld
für das was passiert ist liegt in der
psyche von dem täter in den problemen
die der vielleicht auch in seinem leben
irgendwie hatte und mit seinem kopf und
die verantwortung für das was passiert
ist liegt beim täter und nicht bei mir
einfach weil nach der tat in ja so
nickel war aber auch viel charme da ich
glaube jeder mensch der mal zu sexuellen
handlungen gezwungen würde kann dieses
gefühl von scham ist ein ekliges gefühl
ja die chance klappt sogar da dass ich
das überhaupt erlebt habe und dass ich
das mitgemacht habe
ich hab' ich habe es so satt gehabt dass
niemand darüber redet weil ich selber da
so drunter gelitten habe das niemand
bescheid weiß und das hat sich so
angeschaut und mir dass ich gesagt habe
so ich will halt was machen und das
beste was ich machen kann ist den mund
aufmachen in bezug auf sachen die ich
selber erlebt habe und sobald ich mal
angefangen habe darüber zu sprechen was
mir passiert ist kam von allen seiten
immer mehr menschen nach aus meinem
freundeskreis die mir gesagt haben hat
luisa mir ist mir ist das gleiche
passiert und plötzlich plötzlich kriegt
man so die resonanz ist sind doch
irgendwie sehr viele leute und trotzdem
trotzdem macht keiner den mund auf und
trotzdem wird nie darüber gesprochen und
das kann ja irgendwie nicht sein und das
ist irgendwie das was ich erreichen will
hier habe ich was gedreht
für eine für eine app das ist ein
bisschen was anderes video von letzter
woche habe ich euch heute noch mal ein
paar richtig geile sätze die man
manchmal nach sondern missbrauch zu
hören bekommt und ich kann euch eins
sagen die sätze könnt ihr eins zu eins
übertragen auf jemanden mit einer
körperlichen wunden um denjenigen
aufzuheitern das funktioniert auch da
super ich zeigt sich mal
hey was mit dir passiert naja dann hat
mir nur durch etwas so den oberarm
gebrochen
nein nein wenn doch nicht ich kenne ihn
wirklich da wird sowas niemals machen es
muss sofort verstanden haben
aber du siehst doch herr aber ich dachte
du musstest den ihr habt euch doch vor
gut verstanden oder hey komm mit der
nummer willst du doch nicht nur
aufmerksamkeit oder
[Musik]
ein gesellschaftlich absolut
begrüßenswert dass man über 1000 meter
brett das man so viel dass die publik
werden aber ich begrüße ich hatte ganz
mit kampagne wo er schon 2006 vor dem
tor ohne burki gründete sie das grabtuch
der stifter wo eigentlich über deine
augen vieler unbekannter nuzzolo
sexuelle gewalt erlebt ein sexist oder
sexuell persönlich davon abrate
video-botschaft oder krieg das natürlich
auch nicht wenn man so einen
verständlich diskutiert und eine
vorzeigestadt das heißt er muss ich
überlegt eine anzeige erstattet hatte
ich nicht für die öffentlichkeit
ich habe begriffen dass das dass man das
bedürfnis hat frauen dank der seite ja
sowieso also zum ein ganzer sätze
wirklich so viel beifall im falle dass
man versehen und für die bedürfnisse und
für seine eigene grenze ist dort einer
zeit zu machen unbedingt also für mich
ist einfach ein witz siebers
laut volker finke sind zwölf
sozialstunden berufe das also mit auto
hat das ist ein witz und detailreiche
sicht würde ich zurückblicken wir machen
es einfach damit lohnt das ist einfach
wie mit fair oder es ist keine
gerechtigkeit um
also was nennt man einen daumen nimmt
einem sehr viel also ganz abgesehen vom
für die jungfräulichkeit dass ich ganz
anders thema aber fällt nun hat man das
vertrauen zu anderen menschen ein stück
freiheit
das ist für mich das schlimmste was halt
irgendwo präsent ist wie zum beispiel
als ich jetzt nicht in den lift ihnen
oder wenn ich mit dem auto unterwegs mit
aufbereitetem raum extrem buche ich wenn
ich das so sagen darf
ich habe immer das bedürfnis flüchten
und geschlossene grüne ist es auch nicht
möglich
natürlich schon verletzt jetzt war damit
gerechnet aber mit nie das maß dass die
freundschaft beendet oder b2b frage
gestellt womit primat einfach schon mal
etwas opfer sei
opfer sind eine falknerin und glaubhaft
der [ __ ] geschichte sich so
präsentieren nur wenn wundert's gedanken
macht was für eine posse was passt und
wie eine mini messi zum besten
überbringen
das bild wo ali im kopf und poster also
mehr erwartet wie vom opfer dass es dass
das amt das es traurig ist depressiv das
versteckt und weißt du hast für mich war
immer klar es wird sicher das bild sie
wohl ironie er lässt mich leider
bewusste provokation aus eigenen körper
oder last messages in mein körper gehört
mir und ich könnten 8000 immer noch
niemals 8 aber mein körper entscheidet
4g oder was auch immer das
wahrscheinlich nicht sie muss ich als
opfer mit ehefrau gemüse umstellen muss
man muss angst haben vor dem was andere
könnte danken wenn schlussendlich als
tabuthema sie es passiert jeden tag
räume und ich finde mir seid offen
darüber reden
also ich deine zeit geschafft aus der
opferrolle und bis positiv sage ich
jetzt mal aus dem ereignis zu machen da
muss ich jetzt anderen helfen oder eine
andere anzeige heißt aber gott weiter es
ist sicher nicht einfach und das produkt
das strukturprinzip mannschaft aus
[Musik]